check check check
one two one two three four check check
check
one two one two three four one two test
test test
one
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you
good afternoon
welcome to the natural history museum
you know as a nation we face one of the
most difficult moments
in our history in my view four historic
crises all
at the same time the worst pandemic
in a hundred years that's already killed
nearly two hundred thousand people in
county
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
has cost tens of millions of american
jobs
and counting emboldened white supremacy
unseen since the 60s and a reckoning
on race that's long overdue
and undeniable acceleration
of the punishing reality of climate
change
on our planet and our people on the
lives and livelihoods
which i'd like to talk about now
jill and i continued as i suspect all of
you do is pray for everyone in
california oregon and washington
and across the west as these devastating
wildfires rage on
just as we hold them in our hearts those
who have faced the hurricanes
tropical storms off our coast of florida
north carolina
or like parts of new orleans that in
fact have just been issued an emergency
evacuation order
for hurricane sally floods and droughts
across the midwest
the fury of climate change everywhere
all this year and right now we stand
with our families
who have lost everything the
firefighters the first responders
risking everything to save others and
the millions of americans
caught between relocating during a
pandemic
or staying put as ashes in smoke
pollute the air they breathe
let's think about that people aren't
just worried about
raging fires they're worried about the
air they breathe
about the damage to their lungs parents
already worried about covet 19 for their
children
when they're indoors and now they're
worried about asthma attacks
if their kids are outside over the past
two years
the total damage from wildfires has
reached nearly
50 billion dollars in california alone
50 billion this year alone
nearly 5 million acres have burned
across 10 states
more acreage than the entire state of
connecticut
and it's only september california's
wildfire season typically runs through
october
fires are blazing so brightly smoke
reaching so far
nasa satellites can see them one million
miles away in space
the cost of this year's damage will
again be astronomically high
but think of it from the view on the
ground
in the smouldering ashes loved ones lost
along with the photos the keepsakes all
the memories
spouses and kids praying each night for
their firefighter husband
father wife and mother
will they come home entire community is
destroyed
we have to act as a nation it shouldn't
be so bad
that millions of americans live in the
shadow of an orange sky
they're left asking is doomsday here
and i know i know this feeling of dread
and anxiety extends well beyond the
fires
we've seen record hurricane season
costing
billions of dollars as well last month
hurricane laura intensified
at a near record rate just before its
landfall
along with louisiana and gulf coast
it's a troubling marker not for just the
increased frequency of the hurricanes
but more powerful and destructive storms
they're causing record damage after
record damage to people's homes
lives and livelihoods
and before it intensified and hit the
gulf coast
lara ravaged puerto rico where three
years ago hurricane maria
our fellow americans they are still
recovering
from its damage and devastation
think about that reality our fellow
americans are still putting things back
together from the last big storm
as they face the next one we've also
seen historic flooding in the midwest
often compounding the damage delivered
by last year's floods that cost billions
of dollars in damage
many of you traveled through the midwest
beyond that bus tour and you saw it
this past spring in midland michigan
experienced the flood so devastating
with deadly flash flooding over running
dams
and roadways that have displaced 10
000 residents it was considered
once in a 500 year weather event
but those once in many generation events
they're now happening every year the
past
10 years were the hottest decade ever
recorded the arctic is literally melting
parts are actually on fire
what we're seeing in america in our
communities
is connected to all of this with every
bout
with nature's fury caused by our own
inaction on climate change
more can more americans see and feel
the devastation whether in a big city
small
towns on coastlines or in farmlands
it's happening everywhere and it's
happening now
and it affects us all nearly 200
cities not republican or democratic
cities 200 cities
are experienced the longest stretches of
deadly heat waves
in 50 years requires them to help their
poor and elderly residents
adapt to the extreme heat to simply stay
alive
especially in the homes without air
conditioning which many don't have
our family farmers in the midwest are
facing historic drought
those follow records floods and
hurricanes
sped by wind storms
all this year the speed of those wind
storms has been
incredible when you saw it on television
or saw it in person
it's ravaged millions of acres of corn
soybeans and other crops
their very livelihoods which sustain
their families and our economy for
generation
is now in jeopardy how they pay their
bills this year
will be left to pass on to their kids
and none of this is happening in a
vacuum
recent study showed air pollution is
linked with increased risk of death
from cover 19. our economy can't recover
if it can't build back
with more resiliency more ability to
withstand
extreme weather extreme weather that
will only
come with greater frequency and
intensity
the unrelenting impact of climate change
affects
every single solitary one of us
but too often the brunt falls
disproportionately on communities of
color
exacerbating the need for example for
environmental justice sorry as a bug
speaking of the environment these are
interlocking crises of our time
requires action not denial requires
leadership not scapegoating
it requires the president to meet the
threshold duty of the office
to care to care for everyone to defend
us from every attack seen in unseen
always and without exception
because here's the deal hurricanes don't
swerve to avoid red states or blue
states
wildfires don't skip towns that voted a
certain way
the impacts of climate change don't pick
and choose
that's because it's not a partisan
phenomenon
it's science and our response should be
the same
grounded in science acting together
all of us but like with our federal
response to kova 19
the lack of a national strategy on
climate
on climate change overall leaves us with
a patchwork of solutions as a matter of
fact it's been made worse
by the changes this administration has
made
i'm speaking from delaware we're the
lowest
lying state in the nation relative to
sea level
where just last week delaware state
attorney general
sued 31 31
big fossil fuel companies alleging that
they
knowingly wreaked havoc and damage
on climate our climate damage that is
plain for everyone to see
but the president
as he flies to california today
we know he has no interest in meeting
this moment
we know he won't listen to the experts
or treat this disaster
with the urgency it demands
as any president should do during the
national emergency
he's already said he wanted to withhold
aid to california
to punish the people of california
because they didn't vote for him
this is another crisis another crisis he
won't take responsibility for
the west is literally on fire
and he blames the people whose homes and
communities are burning he says
quote you gotta clean your floors you
gotta clean your forest
this is the same president who threw
paper towels on the people of puerto
rico
instead of truly helping them recover
and rebuild
we know as disdain for our own military
leaders
and our veterans just last year
the defense department reported that
climate change is a direct threat
to more than two two-thirds of the
military's
operationally critical installations
that's what the military warned you
and this could well be this could be
a conservative estimate donald trump
climate denial may not have caused these
fires
and record floods and record hurricanes
but if he gets a second term these
hellish events will continue to become
more common
more devastating and more deadly
and meanwhile donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west
floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial
how many suburbs will be burned in
wildfires
how many suburban neighborhoods will
have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in super storms
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised when more
of america is under water
we need a president to respect science
who understands
that the damage from climate change is
already here
unless we take urgent action
we'll soon be more catastrophic
a president who recognizes understands
and
cares that americans are dying
which makes president trump's climate
denialism
his disdain for science and facts all
the more unconscionable
once again he fails the most basic duty
to a nation
he fails to protect us from the pandemic
from an economic free fall from racial
unrest
from the ravages of climate change it's
clear
that we're not safe in donald trump's
america
this is donald trump's america he's in
charge
what he doesn't get is that even in a
crisis there's nothing beyond the
capacity
of the american people when we stand up
and act together
and while so many of you are hurting
right now
i want you to know that if you give me
the honor of serving as your president
we can and we will meet this moment with
urgency and purpose
we can and we will solve the crime of
the climate crisis
and we'll build back better than we were
before
you know when donald trump thinks about
climate change he thinks hoax
when i think about i think jobs
good paying union jobs to put americans
to work
building a stronger more climate
resilient nation
a nation modernized we have modernized
water and transportation systems
an energy infrastructure to withstand
the impacts of extreme weather
and changing climate when donald trump
thinks about renewable energy
he sees windmills somehow is causing
cancer
i see american manufacturing american
workers racing to lead the global market
i see farmers making agriculture the
first
in the world to achieve net zero
emissions
and in the process gaining new sources
of income
when donald trump thinks about led light
bulbs
he says he doesn't like them because the
lights are no good they always make him
look orange
i see small businesses and master
electricians designing and installing
award-winning energy conservation
measures
rebuilding buildings across the country
it's going to reduce electrical
consumption
and save businesses hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year
in energy cost well he turns against our
allies
i'll bring us back into the paris
agreement i'll put us back in the
business of leading the world
on climate change and i'll challenge
every other country
to up the ante on climate commitments
where he reverses the biden
assuming the obama biden fuel efficiency
standards
he picks big oil he picks big oil
companies over american workers
even when the automobile industry agreed
he'll not only bring the stand i don't
want to bring the standards back
i'll set new ambitious ones that our
workers are ready to meet
i'll also see american workers building
and installing
500 000 electric vehicle charging
stations along our newly engaged
infrastructure programs and highways all
across the country
i see american consumers switching to
electric vehicles through rebates
and initiatives not only that
the united states owns one of them and
maintains an enormous fleet of vehicles
and we're going to harness the
purchasing power
of our federal government to make sure
we're buying
electric vehicles they're made and
sourced
by union workers right here in the
united states of america
and together this will mean more than a
million
new jobs in the american auto industry
you know and we'll do another big thing
it'll put us on a path to achieving a
carbon pollution free
electric sector electricity sector
by 2035 that no future president can
come along and turn back
transforming the electrical sector power
to produce power without carbon
pollution
it'll be the greatest spur to job
creation and economic competitiveness in
the 21st century
not to mention the positive benefits to
our health and our environment
we need to get to work right away
we'll need scientists at the national
labs and land-grant universities
historic black colleges and universities
to improve and innovate technologies
needed to generate
store and transmit this clean electric
we need engineers to design and workers
to manufacture these new
products we'll need iron workers and
welders
to install them we'll need to become the
world's
largest exporter of these technologies
creating even more jobs
sourced in america
we know how to do this the obama biden
administration rescued the auto industry
and helped them retool we made solar
energy
cost competitive with traditional energy
and weatherize more than a million homes
which is just the beginning if we get
reelected
and we'll do it again bigger and faster
and better than before
we'll also build 1.5 million new energy
efficient homes
and public housing units that will
benefit our communities in three times
over
by eliminating an affordable housing
crisis by increasing energy efficiency
and by reducing the racial wealth gap
linked to home ownership
there are thousands of oil and natural
gas wells
that oil companies and gas companies
have abandoned
many of which are leaking toxins we
create 250 000 jobs
now by just plugging those wells right
away
good union jobs for energy workers
this will help sustain communities and
protect them from the environmental
damage as well
we'll also create new markets for our
family farmers and ranchers
we'll launch a new modern civilian
climate corps
to heal our public lands and make use of
us less vulnerable make us much less
vulnerable
to wildfires and floods i believe that
every american has a fundamental right
to breathe clean air and drink clean
water
i know that we haven't fulfilled that
right yet
that's true of the millions of families
struggling
with the smoke-created devastation of
the wildfires right now
but it's also been true for a generation
or more
in places like cancer alley in louisiana
or right here in delaware along the
route 9
carter right here in delaware
fulfilling this basic obligation to all
americans especially
in low-income white black brown and
native american communities
who too often don't have the clean air
in the clean water
is not going to be easy but it's
necessary
i'm committing to get it done these
aren't pie in the sky
dreams these are concrete actionable
problems
that create american jobs mitigate
climate change
and put our nation on the road to net
zero emissions by no
later than 2050.
you know some say we can't afford to fix
this
but here's the thing look around at the
crushing consequences of the extreme
weather events
i've been describing we've already been
paying for it
so we have a choice we can invest in our
infrastructure
to make us stronger more resilient
improving the health of americans and
creating millions of good paying jobs
while at the same time tackling the root
causes of climate change
or we can continue down the path donald
trump has on
a path of indifference costing tens of
billions of dollars to rebuild
when the human costs the lives and the
livelihoods and the homes and the
communities destroyed
are immeasurable we have a choice
we can commit to doing this together
because you know that climate change is
the existential challenge that's going
to determine
our future as a country for our children
our grandchildren and our
great-grandchildren or
we can do it donald trump's way ignore
the facts
deny reality which amounts to a full
surrender
and a failure to lead it's
backward-looking politics
that's going to harm the environment
make communities
less healthy and hold back economic
progress while other countries race
ahead
and it's a mindset that doesn't have any
faith
in the capacity of the american people
to compete to innovate
and to win like the pandemic
dealing with climate change is a global
crisis
that requires american leadership it
requires
a president for all americans
so as the fires rage out west on this
day
our prayers remain with everyone under
the ash
i know it's hard to see the sun rise
believing today will be a better day
than yesterday
americans face this historic inflection
point
a time of real peril but also a time of
extraordinary possibilities
i'm confident i know we can do this
we will do this this is the united
states of america
we've seen the light through the dark
smoke we never give up
always without exception every time
we succeed when we try
may god bless our firefighters and keep
them safe and our first responders
may god protect our troops thank you
very much
i'm anxious to share what the president
had to say thank you